[Music]
home sweet home
that's right I don't have to go in
anymore
[Music]
that sucks I guess I haven't played in
like half a year mmm Oh recommendations
fruits de mer hmm characters and I'm
really diggin the art I'm mode eco mode
EOKA 30 years old recent corporate
dropout and neat I'm not your average
neat schmuck though I chose the neat
life I'm an elite meat he's perfect one
hot guy character I love it
[Music]
what the actual hell possessed me to go
with a name like hi is she I totally
over taught it like I always do
[Music]
all right let's do it
rest in peace I'll get you this time
[Music]
rest in peace okay this time for sure
rest in peace this is actually pretty
hard it's completely different from
non-terrestrial
she's such an angel yeah I'm okay I'm
just stuck on a quest I keep dying and
coming back here I get it now she's so
cute I understand that cause can be
really difficult and you've only just
started playing right
yeah don't worry this game can be a
challenge when you're trying to get the
hang of it but you know what
the scenery makes up for it
[Music]
it's a totally unique world and through
it we get to meet totally new people
I think that's really what makes a
role-playing journey like this one so
much fun
some is too beginner they say no road is
long with good company and even a chance
meeting is due to fate so with that in
mind would you care to adventure
together
[Music]
you're learning to use your sales skills
at the right time the damage you take
[Music]
see you love or dope congratulations are
in order it looks like you're just about
ready to head over to the bathroom the
bus don't worry it'll be fine because
I'll be right there by your side right
just lead the way I'll get you fixed up
in no time
[Music]
I would say healing or hit before my
eyes
[Music]
we could do this
[Applause]
[Music]
I did it so exciting yeah thanks a lot
for your help I you see you've got one
more shot to test your luck hopefully we
can find more good surprises
[Music]
thousand and golden bracelets does this
count as good luck yes at least a bit
awesome looks like we could come a
matching pair pretty car we are he'll
never take them up oh no you can only
clip them when you find something better
no way I'm wearing them forever
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow I can't believe how great that was I
was actually having fun Thank You Lilly
thank you hey Lilly check this out you
can totally get inside the sea anenome
look
[Music]
[Laughter]
is it snowing but why looks like it's
for Christmas even in fruits damira
things can get pretty festive during
holidays kinda gets you in the spirit
huh
yeah it does Christmas I know hey we
should go hunting I just heard a rumor
some new monsters have spawned
sounds good oh I just remembered though
there's actually somewhere I wanted to
go today talk to you later
[Music]
hey sorry I gotta get somewhere yeah I
stopped here on my way home from work it
takes me three hours to get home so I'm
taking a break three hours I know it's a
bit of a trip right you should hurry on
home poco don't you have someone waiting
for you there mmm-hmm you got a point
hi yes you seem pretty at home here now
compared to before remember when you
were in and you had trouble with the
controls he would randomly run off at
full speed during a fight
I'm only doing better thanks to you and
everyone else in the guilt come on let's
put the formalities behind us it's time
to drink so Cheers
[Music]
hey what's the matter you're looking a
little lonely over here got some girl
problems
you know you can always tell your big
brother he Maral to anything okay well
hi oh she and I were in a sea anemone
together and I felt right at home I sort
of feel like I want to play with him
some more because it was so fun
but it seems like he's avoiding me I
wonder if I did something that is a
quandary hmm
so what's this about hi as she I guess
something happened between him and Lily
something like what hiya she and Lily
are our friends like all the members of
at home party and you're the guild
master so you should be the one to go
ask him what's up okay
just kill me it kinda looks like you've
been avoiding Lily lately something
happened there so he invited me to
adventure with you alone just so you'd
be able to ask me about that I'm sure I
told you this when you first entered our
guild romance is prohibited whoa you
really are clueless it is true our guild
does have a no romance policy for
several good reasons and I definitely
don't want any drama but you don't need
to stress about it or anything yeah
because right now I'm going to ask you
this as a friend I'm not asking as your
guild master you're a good gaming buddy
for Lily can you just keep doing that
the way you were with her looks and her
kind heartedness I'm sure you can
imagine what she has to deal with in
terms of creeps sometimes even though
she's just here to forget about work and
relax and anyway there's really no
telling what anyone's true gender is
online gaming is weird man there's no
need to worry games a game the real
worlds the real world it's thanks to
Lily I'm having such a good time here
now so I wanted to give her a token of
appreciation gonna get a certain rare
drop on this quest it's one you can't
buy even with money that's right I'm
giving her a crystal rose as a Christmas
present
dude that's insanely corny no I've given
this a lot of thought and simplest best
luck I know I'm at a low level but I
want to try for it on my own and it's
gonna look like perfection on her so
wait you plan to play straight from now
till Christmas
[Music]
hi hey are you alright
oh yeah I'm fine I kind of went
overboard with a tough quest let me fix
that for you I'll use brother feeling
Thank You hilly I've been looking for
you
I ended up asking Khan Bay where he
thought you might be
tell me do you feel like I've been
getting in your way I know I'm probably
just getting paranoid sitting here on my
own what what's wrong
Lily what happened I don't know what to
say to her how the heck am I supposed to
know how other girls feel I don't know
and I am one wait that's obvious
nevermind it's fine you're doing great
as you are I'm afraid if I say anything
more right now it'll just end up putting
you in a tight spot but you came to see
me for a reason didn't you are you free
on Christmas Eve there's something I
want to give you I actually do have work
but I'll get home as soon as I can
oh great so what you want to do two guys
alone on Christmas Eve want a drink
man don't say that and it's depressing
don't be so serious just a joke well
I've actually got some plans yet update
oh it's not like that hmm
dancy all right good work today thank
you for saying that now
oh great
[Music]
damn stupid couples everywhere just
because it's Christmas frickin Eve
I must retreat it once died
thanks Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
may help the next person find everything
okay thank you very much all right we
made it just please be quiet tummy no
I'm asking the impossible
it's not gonna stunt my stomach is
playing its own jingle bells' I'm gonna
tie the embarrassment anyway I'd rather
die eating yes miss thanks for always
shopping with us excuse me
chicken please please take it great I
won't be able to come to the store for a
while
well I had a lot to deal with but I'm
relieved I still got to log on before
Lily high ever present he's a special
dye you'll be able to use on your gear
once you find something you like thank
you so much I'll be extra careful with
it as for me
I got you this it's a mini rose brooch I
was actually pretty determined to get
you a crystal rose but I'm afraid this
is all I could manage
[Music]
thank you I'm surely overjoyed I believe
gifts like this one really express the
true meaning of the season whereas what
I gave you was just something I paid for
nothing more this year is the best
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
[Music]
by you and needs don't you think there
might be some things that we're all
better off not knowing my name is you
two Sakura I was cool
episode 2 we don't know anything
[Music]
[Applause]